[Music]
what do a milk soil and brass have in
common
didn't get it they are all mixtures air
is a mixture of nitrogen oxygen and many
other gases milk is a mixture of water
fats proteins like ASEAN and
carbohydrates like lactose and so on
similarly soil is a mixture of many
things and brass is a mixture or more
specifically an alloy of copper and zinc
most of the substances that we come
across in our daily life are mixtures of
to a more pure substances we note that a
mixture is not a chemical compound in
all of these examples the different
components in the mixture are not
chemically combined that is they do not
chemically react with each other to form
compounds there is one interesting
characteristic of a mixture its
properties depend on the proportion of
the different components in it to
understand this better let's make two
cups of tea let's say we've added one
sugar cube half a cup of milk and some
tea leaves in this cup and two sugar
cubes 3/4 cup of milk and some tea
leaves in this one since in the second
cup we've added more milk it will be
lighter in color the addition of one
extra sugar cube will also make it taste
sweeter even though we've put the same
components in both the cups of tea there
is a difference in their properties so
we see that the properties of a mixture
depend on its composition but more
appropriately we'd refer to tea as a
solution instead of a mixture right
because tea is a liquid and liquid
mixtures are called solutions is it so
do solution and a mixture refer to the
same thing partially yes in this video
and a few upcoming ones we learn about
solutions which are an important type of
mixture
in front of you there are three glasses
of water in one of them we've added mud
in the other we've added salt and in the
third we've added sugar can you identify
which glass has which mixture just by
looking at them yes you can easily
identify the muddy water but what about
the other two
we can't differentiate between the other
two as both the mixtures look just like
water this is because in these two cases
we cannot see the dissolved salt or the
sugar particles the naked eyes the salt
in the sugar particles are evenly
distributed in water whereas in the
glass with a mud and water
we're easily able to see the mud
particles suspended and settled in the
glass so we can see that there are two
types of mixtures in the first mixture
its composition is not uniform and its
components are in different phases that
is you're able to see the different
components separately so this type of a
mixture which has non-uniform
composition and varying properties is
called a heterogeneous mixture and in
the second and the third mixtures their
composition is uniform throughout and
its components are in a single phase
that is we cannot separately see the
individual components so this type of a
mixture in which its composition and
properties are uniform throughout this
called a homogeneous mixture for example
in a bowl full of mixed nuts it's
possible to identify the different nuts
in the bowl and the composition of the
mixture is not uniform so it's a
heterogeneous mixture can you tell me if
a block of steel is a heterogeneous or a
homogeneous mixture steel is a mixture
of mainly iron and carbon along with
some other elements but these different
components are not visible to our naked
eyes and its composition looks uniform
throughout the mixture so it's a
homogeneous mixture
now these types of homogeneous mixtures
are called solutions that is a solution
is a homogenous mixture of two or more
components so here the mixture of salt
and water the mixture of sugar and water
and steel are all solutions but wait as
we saw before we usually think that
solutions are always in liquid state but
here we mentioned that steel is a
solution yes solutions need not always
be in a liquid state they can be in any
of the three states of matter that is
gas liquid or solid
for example a which is a mixture of
oxygen nitrogen and other gases another
one is carbon dioxide in the soft drinks
where the gas is dissolved in the liquid
so a solution can be in any of the three
states of matter now here's a question
for you we know that the salt dissolves
in water to form a solution does the
same happen when we put salt in oil no
right salt and oil don't mix why is it
so think about it in the upcoming
lessons we are going to understand this
we will see how a solution is formed how
their properties differ from the
components and so on to stay updated and
to keep learning such interesting things
do subscribe to our Channel
[Music]
you